Bosco Ntaganda has been nicknamed by the
people of eastern Democratic Republic of
Congo as the Terminator
he's a former rebel leader accused of
human rights abuses in several parts of
the region
judges are the International Criminal
Court
I found him guilty of crimes against
humanity and war crimes including murder
using child soldiers and sexual slavery
the crimes are committed in Ettore
province between 2002 and 2003 by the
patriotic force for the liberation of
Congo a bell group in tuganda led the
military wing Thomas Lubanga was a head
of the group and is serving 14 years in
jail at the ICC this man says his two
brothers were killed by the fighters we
lost many family members sisters
brothers uncles we also lost a lot of
property eatery might be the focus of
antagonist case but in another town more
than 800 kilometers south victims of a
moussaka where a hundred and fifty
people were killed in one day in 2006
have been following court proceedings
Kinley
they sent agonda was one of the leaders
of rebel fighters who attacked their
villages he said to have been personal
in charge of the q1j killings almost
everyone here in q1j lost a loved one
those we talked to said Bosco Ntaganda
and the fighters he led accuse them of
protecting a rival rebel group they also
say they want justice
killer Warnock Yanam Rebecca you may
choose us huskar's she says her husband
and one-year-old son were killed in
evidence Adrian what's happening within
tuganda should be a deterrent to others
who want to come and terrorize us in the
villages those people destroyed our
lives this part of the country has been
embroiled in armed conflict for decades
thousands of rebel groups control remote
villages and towns
campaigners want the government and
regional bodies to deal with human
rights abuses
gorgey my room we need a proper court
here with proper invest
Gators and justice system people want to
have their day in court and look they're
perpetrators in the eye the ICC is too
far away and disconnected from victims
in the villages in tuganda is the fourth
person to be convicted by the ICC and
during the South paw in it Tory says he
deserves to be in jail for life
Rebecca Newman Kwanza is still waiting
for her justice Katherine soil
al-jazeera Kwanza eastern Democratic
Republic of Congo